i'm your new commanding officer i do not
like amy we'd like you to go undercover
i just got fired from the nypd captain
lunch i was looking for an excuse to
promote you to a death job charles boyle
and i had sex
i'm leaving the nine-nine effective
immediately i'm your new commanding
officer i'm having a heart attack screw
just being colleagues i'm back meet
detective adrian pimento we got engaged
someone's trying to kill me we have more
than enough evidence to take you and
figures down what if we don't find
figures
what are figgis
finds us
i'm transferring the whole squad to the
night shift we're back on the day [ __ ]
lieutenant melanie hawkins dirty this is
an undercover operation that's alive
guilty
will you marry me i'm compromised you're
both gonna die now i'm gonna be a
surgeon i do the nine-nine is at war
with the nypd i'm handing in my two
weeks notice i do want to have kids we
can still stop john kelly
should we just start trying
to took the coke and the guns yeah lunch
is dead we're having a baby meet mac